monsieur laurent habite un complexe
immobilier de laval destiné aux
personnes retraitées de 55 ans et plus
en cette journée ensoleillée il profite
d'une balade extérieur elle sera de
courte durée quand on rencontre des gens
en marchant au par logis piché le même
championnat
ça fait une dizaine de jours qu'on
autorise monsieur laurent et sa
conjointe a effectué une sortie
supervisé par jour d'une quinzaine de
minutes avant cela il a été confiné 24
heures sur 24 depuis la fin mars
je ne connaissais plus puis mon épouse
non plus je n'ai jamais vu péter un
plomb en opt-in coupe depuis et justin
long
les pilot j'en suis demandé jusqu'où ça
va aller est-ce-que je dois mourir du
gone gone au virus ou système u yeux
fous les directives de la santé publique
concernant les résidences privées pour
aînés indique bien que depuis le 23 mars
les sorties sont interdites mises à part
celles pour des fins humanitaires pour
obtenir des services essentiels ou les
sorties extérieures superviser monsieur
laurent et sa conjointe comprennent bien
les consignes même obtenir plus de
sorties les personnes qui le peuvent
peuvent sortir d'or prendre l'air en
notant que cette ses promenades se font
en respectant les règles de
distanciation social var je pense que
des réajustements qui doivent être faits
justement le docteur horacio arruda a
rappelé cette semaine qu'il songe à
alléger les conditions de confinement
des personnes âgées autonomes
soyez sûr il l'objectif n'est pas de
retenir pour retenir deux objectifs fait
pour retenir pour être en mesure de
savoir qu'est ce qui se passe bien
comprendre la dynamique de transmission
on connaît quelqu'un qui est parti le
pays riches ont fait deux valises pigeon
aux petits chiens pouvaient plus la
direction a pris ces mesures pour éviter
la propagation
pour l'instant ils n'ont d'autre choix
que de prendre leur mal en patience
et si mélissa françois radio canada
montréal